قال مراسل الجزيره ان وفدا من اكواس في
النيجر توجه الى القصر الرئاسي للقاء رئيس
المجلس العسكري وذلك بعد ساعات من اعلان
اكواس حسم قاده جيوشها موعده تدخلهم
العسكري المحتمل هناك وكانت التلفزيون
النيجر قد بث صورا لطائرات قال ان مالي
وبوركينا فاسو نشرتها في النيجر استعدادا
لتدخل اكواس الذي اعلنت واشنطن تاييدها له
كملاذ اخير كحل الازمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما فرص نجاح وفد
اكواسفينيامي وما دلاله تشكل حلف وحلف
مضاد على خلفيه الحديث عن تدخل عسكري
محتمل في النيجر وما النتائج المحتمله
لذلك التدخل بالنظر للمواقف الدوليه منه
والى اي حد يمكن ان يمثل اعلان مالي
بوركينا فاسو استعدادهما للدفاع عن النيجر
ونشرهما طائرات فيها عاملا قد يسهم في نزع
فتيل التوتر وما فرص تحول ذلك لمواجهه
اقليميه على اراضي النيجر وعلى اي نحو
يمكن ان تتطور مواقف روسيا والصين
والولايات المتحده وفرنسا من مجريات
الاوضاع في النيجر وما هي المواقف
المتوقعه من هذه الدول ردا على
السيناريوهات المختلفه لتطور الاحداث
[موسيقى]
في تطور قد يكون الفرصه الاخيره للتوصل
الى حل سلمي لازمه النيجر وفق مراقبين
افادت مصادر رسميه في النيجر للجزيره
بلقاء يعقده وفد من منظمه مع المجلس
العسكري والحكومه المعينه من قبل المجلس
العسكري في عاصمه النيجر نيامي
الذي وصل الى النيامي ظهر السبت يتراسه
بحسب تلك المصادر عبد السلام ابو بكر رئيس
نيجيريا السابق ويضم سلطانه سلطنه سكوتو
في نيجيريا
وصوله
جاء بعد ساعات من اعلان المجموعه ان قاده
جيوشها حسموا موعد تدخلهم العسكري في
النيجر رغم رفضها رفض مجموعتك واسال كشف
عن هذا الموعد مفوض الشؤون السياسيه
والسلم والامن في اكواس عبد الفتاح موسى
اعلن في ختام اجتماع قاده جيوش دول لغرب
افريقيا في العاصمه الغنيه اكره ان اي
تدخل في النيجر سيكون قصير الامد وسيهدف
لاستعاده النظام الدستوري ورغم عدم اغلاقه
باب الحوار مع قاده الانقلاب في النيجر
شدد موسى على ان ايكواس لن تنخرط في
مفاوضات لا افق لها وفق قوله
على الجانب الاخر قالت التلفزيون الرسمي
في النيجر ان ضباطه من رئاسات الاركان في
مالي وبوركينا فاسو والنيجر اجتمعوا ضمن
جهود التصدي للتدخل العسكري المحتمل لدول
اكواس وبثت تلفزيون النيجر صورا لما قال
انها طائرات حربيه من مال وبوركينا فاسو
نشرت في النيجر تنفيذا لتعهدات البلدين
بوقوفهما الى جانب نيامه في حال وقوع اي
تدخل عسكري من
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من واكشوط الهيبه
ولد الشيخ سيداتي الخبير في الجان
الافريقي ومن امستردام الدكتور حسني عبيدي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جينيف
ابدا بك سيد الهبه ولد السيداتي ما قراءتك
لتشكيله الوفد الذي ارسل من اكواس الى
النيجر
مرحبا واهلا هذا وفد تشكيلته تشييبي نوع
من الامل الى حد ما او فتح الخطيه الخيار
الدبلوماسي من جديد او استمرار فتحه بشكل
متزامن اللافت في هذا الوفد انه وصوله
اليوم لان يعمل كان ايضا بالتزامن مع وصول
السفيره الامريكيه المعينه جديد عديدا في
والتي قالت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انها لن تقدم اوراق اعتمادها للمجلس
العسكري لكنها في نفس الوقت تمثل جزءا من
الحل نظرا للمشاكل التي كانت حاصله ربما
بين الولايات المتحده
والمجلس العسكري هي خطوات جديده تسابق
الزمن للوقوف امام
بديلا عن التدخل العسكري المحتمل والصعوبه
البالغه العسكري الذي اعلنت عنه الاكواس
امس تواجهه عقبات كبيره ليس ادناها ولا
ابسطها ما على قالت عنه اعلنت
لكن المهم هو ان هذا التمويل ما زالت
تعيقه تشكيله القوه تمويل هذه القوه
وبالتالي فعلا هي هناك اشكالات كبيره
للاكواس تسعى للتدخل العسكري ولا لديها
القدره عسكريا لاعاده بازون على ما اعتقد
حسنا ولكن اذا يعني ظللنا في موضوع الوفد
الذي ارسل دكتور حسني عبيدي هذه اول مره
يقبل فيها قاده الانقلاب الالتقاء بالوفد
ورئيسي وبالتالي
ما دلاله ذلك بالنسبه لك
كل المسارات الدبلوماسيه سيد الهيبه
والساداتي وجود رئيس قبيله السكوتو او
سلطنه كوتو او هذا المكون المشترك بين
النيجيريا والنيجر ما اهميته والى اي مدى
يمكن ان يسهم في ايجاد حل للازمه وجوده في
هذا الوقت
فعلا تشكيله الوفد كما اشرتم لهذا لاله
خاصه وتوقيته له دلاله خاصه هذا التدخل
بين نيجيريا والنيجر التدخل الشعبي التدخل
السياسي تداخل في المصالح حتى وحتى ان
النيجر هي اول من انعقدت فيها قمه الاكواس
واول من صرح رئيسها نيجيريا تعتبر انها
المعنيه اولا بقضيه النيجر نيجيريا مختلفه
داخليا على ما يحدث على التدخل العسكري
كما تعلمون الولايات المحاذيه التي
تنحدر السلطان منها كثير منها عبر عن رفضه
لتدخل العسكري المجلس الشيوخ النيجري عبر
عن رفضه للتدخل العسكري اذا نيجيريا هي
الليونه للخط اللين الوحيد في الاكواس رغم
قساوته ايضا رسميا الى ان الا ان النيجر
الشعبيه نيجيريا الشعبيه على تماس وتداخل
كبير مع النيجر ويمكن ان تكون تشكل حلا كل
الضغوط حتى الان من اجل
حل توافقي لا غالبه ولا مغلوب فيه لم تعيد
الدبلوماسيه في افريقيا اطلاقا وللوفود
الدبلوماسيه اي
[موسيقى]
انا اعتقد انه لا يوجد هناك اي تناقض ما
بين التلويح بتدخل العسكري وبين ابقاء
الباب مفتوح
اقول ان هذه اول مره يقبل فيها قاده
الانقلاب بلقاء الوفد ورئيسه فهل يعني هذا
ان الضغط عليهم قد نجح بنسبه ما
من المؤكد ان
الموقف الذي ما زال الى حد الساعه متمسكا
بفرضيه التدخل العسكري لديه تاثير في
القبول مباشره استقبال الوفد بعد وصوله
الى نيابه ثم ان النقطه الثانيه كل
تصريحات التي تاتي من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تذهب في نفس الاتجاه وهو انه
لابد من اعاده المجال اعاده النظام
الدستور وبالتالي من مصلحه كذلك
الانقلابيين اعطاء صوره مغايره لهم لانهم
في النهايه لديهم يتمتعون بمرونه بمرونه
باستطاعتهم كذلك التفاعل خاصه حول مستقبل
الرئيس محمد بازوم او حول خريطه طريق
الانتقال الدبلوماسي لكن قبول التفاوض لا
يعني في النهايه قبول كل شروط
الساداتي تدخل بوركينا فاسو ومال بارسال
هذه الطائرات الى اي مدى يمكن ان يكون
مؤثرا
المنطقه في حال تدخل عسكري لا يمكن ان
نتنبا
بمصاره ولا بمالاته يمكن ان تنطلق الشراره
الاولى وتتحكم الاكواس في اللحظه التي
حددت لذلك لكنها لا يمكن اطلاقا كما قالت
ان تكون تدخلا عسكريا خاطفا سريعا المنطقه
ستدخل دوامه خطيره جدا بوركينا فاسو ومالي
معنيه تاني بشكل مباشر بما يحدث ليس لي
هذه الخطوه بالنسبه لي اي دلاله لا
الطبيعه عسكريه خاصه ان البلدين مالي تفقد
السيطره على حوالي خمسين الى اربعين في
45% من اراضيها بسيطره الجماعات المسلحه
بوركينا تفقد حوالي السيطره على حوالي 40%
من ارضها بالتالي هذا ليست له دلاله لا
يمكن لي مالي وبوركينا فاسو ان تحمي
النيجر وهي لا
تحمير جزء من اراضيها لكن الدلاله الرمزيه
في التضافر وفي التكاتف وفي دخول المنطقه
في تحالف جديد يهدد حتى سياسيا بالانسحاب
بمنظمه الاكواس التي كانت في الفتره
الاخيره قبله لكثير من الدول الافريقيه
اصبحت الان تتاكل هذا هو المؤشر السياسي
وهي الدلالات السياسيه القويه المؤثره على
هذا القرار وعلى الانقلابيين اليست اليهود
دلاله اخرى وعلى حتى على الاكواس هذا
السؤال اوجهه لك ايضا دكتور حسين عبيدي
يعني هل تعتقد ان اعلان مالي وبوركينا
فاسو انهما سيرسلان او انهما ارسلاه
بالفعل طائرات حربيه هذا قد
يثني او يسهم في اثناء اكواس عن اي تدخل
عسكري في المستقبل القريب
لكن يعني بميزان القوى يعني لا يزن كثيرا
في النهايه ولا يمكن يؤثر فعلا على القدره
القتاليه لدول الاكواس لكن هو في النهايه
مؤشر على شيء اخطر من ذلك وهو ان التوجه
لايكوست والمعالجه العسكريه والحاده نوعا
ما التي استثمرت الدبلوماسيه منذ البدايه
فقط اعتدت الى الدبلوماسيه في الاخر
ينبئ بشيء خطير في افريقيا وهو قضيه
البناء مخاور يعني محاور جديده
منظمات جديده كذلك اصبح التدخل العسكري
بالنسبه لخيارا متاحا اكثر من الاتحاد
الافريقي لانه في النهايه الافارقه دائما
هناك منظمه الاتحاد الافريقي هناك مفوضيه
الامن والسلام لفي لمعالجه هذه القضايا
وبالتالي هذا الموضوع يؤدي بالدول الرافضه
لهذا المنحنى لهذا لهذه المعالجه البحث
الامن العسكريه في التفكير في محاور جديده
ما قامت به في النهايه رغم انه رمزي
بوركينا فاسو ومالي هو مؤشر على ان هناك
رغبه ربما يعني هناك تسع دول فقط ابدت
استعدادها لكن الباقين بين بين الحياه
وبين الرفض وهذا فعلا يمكن يؤدي بهذه
الدول ان تفكر مليا سواء في بقايا او
التفكير في تجمع
هذه الخطوه مما لا يبركينا فاسو سيد الهبه
والساداتي رمزيه وتبقى رمزيه ام ام يعني
اذا ما طرحت سؤال بهذا الشكل ما فرص ان
يتحول هذا الى صراع اقليمي يضم النيجر
وبوركينا فاسو ومالي وربما دول اخرى يعني
لا تكون ساحه المعركه ارض النيجر فقط
بكل تاكيد في حال حدث تدخل عسكري سيكون
لتداعيات القضيه كبيره جدا لا يمكن ان
يعود الى السلطه في النيجر دون عوده ثقيله
في على الحدود الجماعات المسلحه تسيطر
وتقتل في النيجر
الجزء الشمالي من نيجيريا ايضا يلتهب اذن
المنطقه وفيه بقوه حرام اذا المنطقه
ملتهبه جدا واي تدخل عسكري سيزيد من
الانقسامات والمشاكل الامنيه الكبيره
والموجوده اصلا ليبيا تشاد السودان هذه
الصحراء الكبرى ستزداد تعقيدا سيزداد
العنفو فيها لا يمكن اطلاقا ان تكون نهايه
مريحه او عمليه سياحيه خاطفه لا اطلاقا
ستكون هناك مشاكل كبيره امنيا مشاكل في
المنطقه
مالي وبوركينا فاسو تشعران بان في حال
نجاح اعاده بازون ولو بمربع
المربع المنطقه الخضراء كما في بغداد
لرئيس في منطقه محدوده سيكون له اثر كبير
على السلطه في مالي والسلطه في بوركينا
فاسو ستبدا الانقلابات التي شهدت خلال
سنوات الثلاثه الماضيه ست انقلابات في
المنطقه ستبدا بالتراجع او ستستمر في
الانقلابات في برقيه دول غرب افريقيا هذا
هو السؤال هذا هو المؤشر وهو الذي ينظر
اليه الجميع فدوافع الدول التسعه التي
ترفض الاعلى مندفع الان لرفض
الانقلاب في النيجر والمستعده للتدخل
العسكري دوافعها بالاساس دوافع ذاتيه خوفا
من انتشار العدوى ومالي وبوركينا فاسو
ودوافعهم ايضا للدفاع عن دوافع عن
مكاسبهم السياسيه وعن انقلاباتهم سابقه
ليس حبا في النيجر وليس دفاعا على الصعيد
المواقف الدوليه من هذه الازمه ازمه
النيجر جددا الاتحاد الاوروبي رفضه
الاعترافه بالسلطات التي تمخض عنها
الانقلاب امل الولايات المتحده التي وصلت
وصلت سفيرتها الى اليامي دون تقديم اوراق
اعتمادها الى سلطات الانقلاب اكدت في
تصريحات للمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ادلى بها للجزيره تاييدها
المبدئي لخطه بشان الحفاظ على النظام
الدستوري في النيجر من خلال الوسائل
السلميه وترك الخيار العسكري كملاذ اخيره
كما ذكر المتحدث ون واشنطن تركز حاليا على
الجهود الدبلوماسيه للتواصل الى حل سلمي
يحافظ على الديمقراطيه التي اكتسبتها
النيجر بالشق الانفس على حد تعبيره
دكتور حسني عبيدي كيف نفهم الموقف
الامريكي بدايه من ارسال السفيره دون
تقديم اوراق اعتماد
يعني في العلاقات الدوليه عندما ترسل
سفيره الى السلطه قائمه صحيح غير معترف
بها لكنها هي التي تدير امور البلاد يعتبر
اعتراف ضم ضمني حتى وان لم تقدم اوراق
اعتمادها فكيف يمكن لدول اجنبيه ان تشن
هجوما كما يقول بيان اكره يكون خاطف فقط
في عدد النظام يعني لوجسيه من الصعب جدا
ان تقوم بهذه العمليه النقطه الثانيه هو
في موقف ضعف لانه كان فرنسا تنتظر من موقف
اكثر قوه من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهو عدم التخاطب وعدم التفاوض الا من خلال
الاكواس مع السلطات الجديده في النيجر
الولايات المتحده لم تلتزم بذلك وحتى في
البيان كل البيانات وزاره الخارجيه صحيح
تقول بان اعاده النظام الدستوري لكن تركز
دائما على الخيار الدبلوماسي الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما تعلم هناك يعني مبدا التضامن
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ومتضامن مع فرنسا
لكن ليس بدرجه
ولكن لو سمحت لدكتور حسني الامريكيون هذه
المره يقولون انهم يدعمون موقف الاكواس
بما في ذلك الخيار العسكري كما اخير هذه
النقطه ما الذي تضيفه
صحيح لكن في نفسه يقولون بانهم الخيار
العسكري لابد قبل كل شيء ان يسبق بكل
المحاولات الدبلوماسيه والاحد الساعه
لاول مره يعني يكون هناك لقاء دبلوماسي
وانا اعتقد انه بعد هذا اللقاء عفوا بعد
هذا اللقاء التشاور ولقاء التفاوض المساحه
التعبير من المؤكد ان سيكون هناك عمليه
رسائل ما بين الانقلابيين وبين الاكواس
وبالتالي من الصعب القول او التسريع
بعمليه عسكريه في حين ان عمليه جست النبض
والتفاوض الغير رسمي بدات منذ اليوم
كيف نفهم ايضا ان قاده الانقلاب قبلوا ان
تكون هناك سفيره للولايات المتحده دون
تقديم اوراق اعتماد اليه
الراجح ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لديها خيوط وعلاقات واتصالات بالمجموعه
الانقلابيه في النيجر مؤشرات ذلك واضحه
وستتكشف اكثر من اجتماع اليوم اولها الضغط
من اجل هذا الاجتماع وتزامن انعقاده مع
حضور السفينه الجديده الراجح ان
الانقلابيين سيقدمون اليوم مقترحا
دبلوماسيا لتمكينهم سيكون فرصه للنقاش
وبدء النقاش امور اخرى في المجال
الدبلوماسي تطيل
الوقت وتضيعه وتضيع الوقت على التدخل
العسكري وتمكن اكثر الانقلابيين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا جربت دعم فرنسا في
مالي وفي بوركينا فاسو وكانت النتيجه
طردها وطرد فرنسا والتمكين لروسيا
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
تريد ان تتكرر لها التجربه في مالي وفي
بوركينا في النيجر التي توجد بها اثناء
اكبر قاعده عسكريه لطائرات المسيره في
خارج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتي
يوجد بها ثروات مهمه تستثمر فيها الشركات
الامريكيه على ذكر القاعده العسكريه دكتور
حسني عبيدي اذا مكانه الولايات المتحده
تقول انها تؤيد موقف اكوس وتؤيد التدخل
العسكري كملاذ اخير لا نقول غدا ولكن كما
اخير فكيف يمكن ان يترجم هذا التاييد يعني
هل يمكن ان تشارك هذه القاعده العسكريه
للمسيرات وهي الاكبر من نوعها خارج
الولايات المتحده تشارك في العمليات
العسكريه مثلا كيف يمكن ان يكون التاييد
بقرار من الولايات المتحده
وحدها قادره على ضمان غطاء جوي مهم جدا
لانه قوتها موجوده في المطار وكذلك موجوده
غير بعيده يعني حتى في في تشاد هناك
العديد من القواعد العسكريه القواعد
العسكريه الفرنسيه لكن سؤالك في النهايه
يطرح قضيه ما هي الضمانات قدره
الانقلابيين على اعطاء ضمانات للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وقدرتهم كذلك على
الحفاظ على هذه الضمانات اعتقد ستكون هي
في النهايه مفتاح الحل بالنسبه للنيجر حل
عسكري او في النهايه تطويل هذه المفاوضات
والتقليل من سيناريو وتدخل عسكري هذا
الدعم لموقفه اكواس وانا دائما اعود الى
موضوع الخيار العسكري لا نعرف انه سوف
يحدث حتما ولكن اذا ما حدث كيف يمكن ان
ينعكس هذا التاييد الامريكي الفرنسي على
الموقفين الروسي في المقام الاول وبعد ذلك
الصيني في النيجر وفي هذه المنطقه
دكتور حسني سؤالي نعم يعني
في مشكله يعني هنا وهي قضيه صحيح قضيه
فاجنر اذا لاحظت معي كل تقريبا المقابله
رئيس الوزراء المعين لنيويورك تايم اهتمام
جدا بفاكر والنفيتام لان تكون في النهايه
القاعده جديده منصه جديده
وهذا الامر مهم جدا بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهما تبحث عنه وهي تعلم
بان القيادات العسكريه بالمناسبه جزء منها
تدرب كذلك من خلال دورات تدريبيه نظمتها
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي هناك علاقات
مستمره مع هؤلاء القيادين العسكريين فانا
اعتقد الولايات المتحده يمكن فعلا ان تكون
هي الدوله الرابعه لاي تدخل عسكري اما
بالنسبه لفرنسا كذلك اعتقد بان اذا تحصلت
على ضمانات من خلال الايكوس او التي هي
تقوم سواء بالتفاوض بالوكاله او اذا كان
هناك خيار عسكريه حرب بالوكاله اذا تحصلت
كذلك فرنسا على ضمانات مهمه جدا عسكريه
تتواجدها العسكري وكذلك اقتصاديه فانا
اعتقد باختصار اذا سمحت لي حتى انتقل
للسيد الهيبه باختصار حيث يمكن ان ينعكس
ذلك على الموقف الروسي دكتور حسني باختصار
لو سمحت
يعني روسيا تدخل عندما يكون هناك فراخ
امني لحد الساعه لا يوجد هناك وبالتالي
الظروف غير مهيئه بالنسبه لروسيا ولا
اعتقد ان كذلك السلطه جدا في النيجر من
مصلحتها حسنا
استاذ الهيبه كيف تنظر الى المستقبل
المنظور في ضوء كل ما ذكرناه وذكرته انت
واشبت الى ان هناك خيوط اتصال معينه بين
امريكا وقاده الانقلاب هل ترى ان هناك حلا
قريبا في الافق ام ان الارجح الحل العسكري
الراجح عندي ان الحل العسكري حتى هذه
اللحظه سيظل مستبعدا نظرا لمالاته المخيفه
اتوقع ان يكون فعلا هناك حل دبلوماسي
للتمكين لشيل جديد من الانقلابيين او
تنظيم انتخابات لا يحضر فيها قاده
الانقلابيون مثل الحلول التي كانت تحدث مع
كل انقلاب في السابق هذا هي الحلول
المطروحه والحلول الدبلوماسيه التي تسعل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وربما فرنسا
كيف كيف يكون الحل نتحدث عن مرحله
انتقاليه ان الينسب زوم مثلا باختصار ايضا
ستكون فعلا هناك مراحل ككل النهايات لمثل
هذا النوع من الانقلابات الحلول هي اماء
ان تكون هناك انقلاب انتخابات في فتره
محدده قصيره او تطول حسب المفاوضات
انتقاليه تتنظم في انتخابات يتم فيها
استبعاد القاده الجيش من الترشح لهذه
الانتخابات وهنا يكون للسياسيين
القدره على تنويم اوراقهم
ليس من الطعمه العسكريه
نعم شكرا جزيلا من نواكشوط الهيبه ولد
الشيخ سيداتي الخبير في الشان الافريقي
ومن امس الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]